[Music]
unit 2 is the backstage area still
secure
this is where all the training pays off
pardon me terribly sorry not a problem
keep your eyes open boys
waiting to communicate
[Music]
wolf is in position
piranha y'all penguin student
affirmative i'm a clean mean donkey
stealing machine what's going on guys
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
here let me help you
are you okay ma'am
oh my gracious yes i may be dizzy like
i'm alive thanks to you
thank you dear
you're such a good boy
[Music]
on the outside
the five of you are villains
predators
[Music]
and this is the crew mr snake serpentine
safe cracking machine imagine houdini
but with no arms
jackpot yes
miss tarantula our in-house tech wizard
where'd you learn to do that mostly
youtube mr piranha he's brave crazy
papa
and mr shark master of disguise his
greatest trick stealing the mona lisa
disguised as the mona lisa
and rounding out the crew is me the big
bad wolf we may be bad but we're so good
at it
we're out
well this just got a little weird
if only we were given a chance to be
anything more than criminals if you want
to stay out of jail you need to go good
what are you doing we're gonna pretend
to go good the bad guys become the good
guys so we can stay in the band guys
it's fantastic
you're a genius
welcome to the first day of the rest of
your best life look it's a cat stuck in
a tree what does your heart tell you to
do a good person would smack it in it
stab it saute this is so obvious i want
you to save it
the good guy we're more than just scary
villains they love us you're such a good
boy
maybe i don't want to be a what a bad
guy no no no
we'll always be bad guys
let's try something simpler i'm going to
give you a push-pull just for me no to
share this is going to taste extra
squeaky
nope
sucka
totally worth it
[Music]